well i want to show you this i this
literally just came up while i'm talking
to i just searched it on google so
let me try to share screen and just kind
of show this to you i want to hear your
thoughts on this so this is from gallup
so gallup shows let me know if you can
see it i can see yeah go ahead
okay so gallup shows that since 2012
till today american self-identification
as
lgbt went from three and a half percent
to three six three seven
three nine now five point six percent
identify as lgbt up two percent from
just
eight years ago to 2020. so and gallup
is pretty
center you know it's not left or it's
right where
you know like for example maybe i'll
take a different angle with this i don't
have to go necessarily to this let's
take another one
i'm speaking at a conference they invite
me to speak
group of pastors hey marketing they
wanted me to talk specifically on the
marketing
side hey why is you know money being
given to churches down
christian not denomination not
necessarily under the denominator
specifically non-denomination
why is it down you know these young
people just don't get it anymore
and i said you know what go to mormon's
youtube channel
so if you go to mormon's youtube channel
mormonism is up okay
you go to a bunch of churches they're up
non-denomination is low
okay why is that what are you guys doing
that you weren't doing before right okay
here's another one for you the argument
of atheists
that argument wasn't that high 50 years
ago
okay we had it don't get me wrong of
course we've had it for a long time this
isn't a new thing
thomas jefferson had an element of
debating the existence of god so it's
not a new thing i'm not sitting here
telling you everybody always believed in
god
but you'll hear a lot of people say
things like this you know i used to be a
jew
i used to believe in all this other
stuff and i used to be catholic i used
to be a christian
but listen we're much smarter today you
know we know let's face it there is no
god what are you talking about it's been
proven all this other stuff
is that because we're smarter or is that
because
the people on tv and social talking
about that god doesn't exist has
increased the percentage of that message
being given where people are starting to
say
you know what maybe you're right god
doesn't exist i'm trying to see how much
of that's being influenced from media
i think it's uh it's several factors
whether it be the lgbtq data that you
shared from gallup or whether it be the
atheism example that you gave
so one possibility is by creating
a quote safer environment for someone to
truly identify as an atheist when in the
past it was difficult for me to do so
or to truly identify as a member of the
lgbtq
community whereas earlier i would have
been ostracized by my family and kicked
out of my small town in the
southern usa then those those patterns
go up
not so much because they are now more
lgbtq people but because people are more
comfortable admitting to who they are so
that's one possibility
but there's a slightly more i mean not
sinister but
you know less clear example and actually
i had a guest on my show
it hasn't er the conversation hasn't
aired her name is abigail schreier
she wrote a book where she basically
argued
that the increase in transgender
young women so biological women who now
self-identify as male is
akin to a social contagion right in
other words in the same way that a
contagion can spread
ideas also spread and so for whatever
reason
it becomes intoxicating to be a member
of that
identifiable group so the next question
you can ask me well why would every
anybody
ever want to self-identify as a
member of a marginalized group like the
lgbtq folks people
and here actually i'm going ahead to uh
my
latest book i actually explained this
using using something called a
psychiatric disorder called
munch housing syndrome can i take a
minute or two to explain please
so in 2010 i had written a scientific
paper in a medical
journal on munchausen syndrome which is
the mechanism whereby someone
feigns a illness so that they can
garner the empathy and sympathy that
comes with having that illness
munch house and syndrome by proxy is
even more diabolical because this is
when
you have someone under your care your
elderly parent
your pet or typically your biological
child
you harm them you physically harm them
so that you can then
garner the empathy and sympathy by proxy
oh poor you
you're a parent of an ailing child so i
was trying to understand
the evolutionary reason why biological
mothers would harm their children
to get that ego stroke so now i'm gonna
tie it in with that social contagion
that i just talked about
well to the extent that it now becomes a
form of victimhood to be a member of a
marginalized group
i can get my ego strokes my empathy and
sympathy
by being a member of that group you
follow now as you might imagine
abigail schreier got into a lot of
trouble
because quote she was erasing the voices
of those transgendered kids
now she wasn't saying that
transgenderism doesn't exist she wasn't
saying that we should be bigoted towards
transgenderism she was simply saying
that for some of the people they aren't
truly transgender
they are simply succumbing to a social
contagion so to go back to finalize with
your gallup poll
i suspect that some of that uptake is
due to the social contagion effect
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye